[تصفيق]
كتير الكارات قليل البراد صح ولا لا كم
حدا فينا سمع هذه الجمله او حدا قال له
هاي الجمله بشكل مباشر
انا اول حدا لما البكالوريا كانوا دايما
بيسالوني انه بعض البكالوريا اي مجال راح
اكمل او تخصص الجامعه اللي راح اكمل فيه
بصراحه كان عندي كتير يعني تخصصات كنت احب
ادخلها بهذاك الوقت كان في صيدله كان في
تاريخ ازار رياضيات صح اكلاتهم
كان في عندي عده اهتمامات بس بالاخير دخلت
اقتصاد بعد هيك بلشت اتفضى اكثر للقراءه
كانوا يسموني دوده كتب هداك الوقت
كنت بقرا حرفيا كل شيء يعني تاريخ سياسي
حروب جغرافيا تاريخ اي شيء كل شيء كنت
بقراه مع كتب الطبخ
بعد هيك بلشت بقى انه اتعلم شي كرمال
اشتغل وبلشت باداك الوقت ترجمه صنعت
محتواك بتعلم
تسويق تصميم حتى تعلمت برمجه وكل هاي
القصص بس وين المشكله كانت المشكله كانت
انه دايما كان في اشخاص كان بيقولوا لي
انه ساره بدك تروقي شوي لانه اذا ما
تخصصتي فالعالم ما رح تعرفك بشي معين وهيك
انت بتكوني عم تضيعي على حالك فرص كتير
الموضوع بصراحه سبب بقلق يعني فكره انه
انا حدا يعني بتعلم كتير وعندي حب اني انا
اتعلم كتير شغلات بس في احتمال انه في
عالم تتميز اكثر والى اخره بس لانه انا
كنت بحب اكثر من شيء يعني
بلشت هيك اعاني من الازمه ما بقى اذا
بسموها ازمه عشرينات انا اخترعتها
لحد ما مره
كانت عم تحكي عن مصطلح اسمه مالتي بوتنشلي
قال شو يعني شخص متعدد ان كانت الشخص
المتعدد الامكانات هو حدا عنده اكثر من
مهاره عنده اكثر من تخصص
بحب يتعلمون وممكن يكون بارع باكثر من
واحد او ممكن يكون ببساطه بارع بانه هو
يخلق المزيج الخاص فيه
ببساطه بيكون مبدع بس لانه هو خلق شي
متميز يتميز فيه برا هذا التخصص الواحد
اللي احنا بنعرفه
بعد ما بلشت يعني شغل بمجال الاول هو كان
شغفي الاول ولحد هلا اللي هو الترجمه
وصناعه المحتوى اول مشكله كانت نشوفها
دائما كنا اكيد انتم بتوافقوني عليها هي
اللي هي المحتوى العربي ضعيف المحتوى
العربي
نسبته نسبيا خلينا نقول لقليله مقارنه مع
المحتوى الثاني لما ندور على شيء ما ندور
عليه بالعربي وهذا الشيء يمكن كلنا بنشوفه
في عنا مشكله انه المحتوى بحد ذاته هو
معنى مناسب للسياق العربي الامثله تبعيته
او كل المواضيع هاي في في ضعف
هذاك الوقت كنت دايما بفكر انه اكيد انا
ما حاجي اقلب الموازين اوكي انا بحب الاقي
حل بس اكيد انا ما حاجي اقلب الموازين
والاقي هذا الحل الخارق اللي بحل قصه
المحتوى كلها بتصور كل حدا فيكم بمجال
شغله شاف شيء مشابه مشكله مشابهه يعني
دائما بكون عم نفكر انه هاي نحن نعرف الحل
ممكن يكون حل ابداعي بصراحه بس في عنا
مشكله وحده يلي هي انه نحن لحالنا كفره ما
فينا نشتغل هذا الشيء لحالنا نكون عم نفكر
انه نحن بدنا فريق كبير بدنا تمويل كبير
خلونا نشوف فلان هي بتمول او خلونا نشوف
جهه تانيه او تتبنى المشروع او الى اخره
بالنسبه لالي بالمحتوى كانت بفكر بنفس
الطريقه انه انا شخص لحالي اذا بدي ادعم
المحتوى العربي شلون رح يكون عم بشتغل
بالسنه عم نحكي عن يعني خلينا نقول
بالاضافه لشغلي عم بحكي عن مقالات هيك عم
بشتغلها كرمال ادعم فيها مواضيع انا بحبها
او مهتمه فيها
يعني خلينا نقول 30 مقال مثلا بالسنه طيب
انا حقول لكم بدل 30 مقال شلون قدرنا نوصل
ل 500 مقال بالسنه وهذا الشيء بلش بالجهود
فرديه
بعدين انتقل لصار شي اكبر وصار فيه فعلا
انه جهد الفردي صار بيتعمم اكبر وممكن
يعمل منه نموذج لحتى يحل مشكله نحن
بالعاده بنعاني منها باي مجال كان رح احكي
لكم القصه اللي انا بلشت فيها
تقريبا بعد ما بلشت هيك بمجال تدريب وصار
في عندي خبره فيه عملت مثل تدريب سميته
سبارك على هذا التدريب كان هو مثل
الاستجابه لظروف اللي كانوا منعاني فيها
بشباب بشكل عام اللي هي موضوع الاسعار
وموضوع البطاله وموضوع انه ما في فرص
عملوا الى اخره فكان الهدف من التدريب انه
انا اكون عم بخلق وعم بدرب اشخاص
بمجال صناعه المحتوى
واساعدهم انهن يبلشوا الكبير طبعا بهذا
المجال
التدريب شلون كان كان عباره عن تدريب
داخلي يعني مثل ما اي شيء بتعمله او مثل
اي تدريب تعملوا شركه معينه من باب
المسؤوليه المجتمعيه او من باب اي شيء هذا
الشخص بيجي وانا كنت بدفع مقابل التدريب
اللي هو بيحصل عليه هو مثل موظف خلينا
نقول
كان في بالبدايه حوالي عشر المتدربين كنا
نشتغل معهم بتدريب عملي طويل
هلا الفكره انه بالاضافه لهذا التدريب كان
في منصه اولى اللي هي
المخبر السلوكي وكان في منصه تانيه اللي
هي
المخبر السلوكي هو كان
عن الاقتصاد السلوكي هو كان اول موقع
بالعربي عم بتصل اللي هو جوهر تخصصي
بالجامعه الموقع الثاني كان عن الصحه
النفسيه
وهذول الموقعين كانوا عم يشتغلوا بالتوازي
مع التدريب شلون يعني لما الشخص كان بيدخل
تدريب هو بحاجه لحتى يفرجي العالم او حتى
مجرد ما خلص لازم يكون في عنده معرض اعمال
صح يعني هو لما نروح اي شخص يروح عند زبون
لحتى يشتغل معه رحله اول شيء فرجينا عن
اعمالك فكان في موقعين على التوازي
هذا الموقعين هدفهم انه كل حدا بشتغل مقال
بكون عم بنوجد هذا المقال على الموقع واحد
او اثنين وبنفس الوقت المقالات هاي عم
تنزل باسماء الاشخاص وبالتالي هنا قادرين
يعملوا نماذج او معرض لاعمالهم
والمقالاتهم عم تنزل باسمه فرجوها لاي
زبون انه نحن اشتغلنا بهذا المجال
اول خلينا نقول اول تجربه كانت واول نسخه
يعني اذا بدنا نسميها من التدريب كانت مثل
ما حكيت انا كنت بدفع لهدول الاشخاص مقابل
تدريب هلا هذا النموذج ما كان كتير ناجح
السبب انه تكلفته ماديا عليه كانت كبيره
هاي من جهه من جهه تانيه
الالتزام اللي انا كنت ما توقعته او
الاقبال اللي انا كنت متوقعته لسبب
فقررت اني انا اعمل نموذج ثاني يلي هو ما
حدا يدفع للثاني يعني انت حابب تتعلم تفضل
انا عم بخصص من وقتي كرمال اني انا اعمل
هذا التدريب واكون عم بتابع هذا الشغل
اللي عم بيصير
بالمقابل خلاص انت فيك تشتغل على هذا
الشيء خلال شهرين مثلا كنا نحدد والى اخره
وبعدها هيك صار في عندك يعني مرض اعمال
حوالي 15 او 20 مقال ونحن بنفس الوقت
بنكون كسبنا شيء او اضافه للمحتوى العربي
اللي هو موجود بهذول المنصتين كمان هذا
الشيء ما كان مجدي كتير السبب الواحد يعني
خلينا نقول هو انه ما كان في التزام ابدا
يعني طالما انه الشخص لا هو عم يدفعه
الاخر ما كان في هذا الالتزام ابدا فقررت
اني اجرب نموذج ثالث نموذج الثالث انه هذا
الشخص بيجي بدفع على التدريب مثل تدريب
تاني لكن في له مزايا مثل ما حكينا انه هو
حضر تدريب وانما كانت كل شي مدخلات عم
ترجع الالو انا بالمقابل كل شيء كان عم
ينشغل كنا عم نعيد تدقيقه ونراجعه علميا
لحتى ينزل
بالمنصه اللي حكينا عنه الفكره مو بس هيك
الفكره انه عائدات التدريب اللي كانت تجي
هي صح كانت مبالغ نوعا ما رمزيه بس كنا
يعني منشيلهم منحطها للتكاليف التشغيليه
تبعيت الموقعين يعني سواء كنا عم نحكي او
سواء كنا عم نحكي عن سواء كنا عم نحكي عن
دومين وهويه بصريه واي شيء كنا هاي
المبالغ كانت بترصد لحتى المشروع يضلوا عم
تشتغلوها وبالتالي انا بضل عم بشتغل
بمشروعين بتكلفه اصفر وهذا الهدف الاساسي
اللي كان منه
بعد هيك يعني كان في بعض الجوانب يعني ما
بخفيها اللي هي كان انه مشروعين صح بدهم
جهود ثاني هون وظفت كل الشغلات اللي انا
كنت بعرفها وكانت فرصه لالي اصلا اني انا
اجرب فيهم يعني كل المواضيع اللي انا
جربتها اتعلمهم ما لقيت مكان اجرب فيهم
وما اشتغل فيهم كنت بجربهم وكان في نتائج
حلوه عم تطلع هلا بعد هيك يعني كان في عنا
حوالي 50 شخص متدرب بعض منه نخلص فتره
الشهرين تدريب او ثلاثه شهور حسب الاتفاق
وخلص يعني هو فعليا تقريبا اذا نحكي نسب
تقريبا 80% 80% منهم بلش شغل لحاله فرنسي
الفكره انه في جزء منهم حب يكمل تطوع يعني
هو خلص مرتاح للقصه
واعمل بالموضوع هذا او هو بحب يكتب
المواضيع اللي احنا عم نشتغل عليها فخلص
هو صار يكمل تطور
هلا رح نحكي عن المخرجات ارقام
خلينا نقول في عنا في المنصه الاولى يلي
هي ستيجما في عنا حوالي
تقريبا ممكن يكون عم نحكي عن
150 مقال توعوي بشكل عام زائد عملنا حوالي
60 اضطراب نفسي كنا عم نغطيه بمحتوى هو ما
كثير موجود بالعربي هو طبعا توعوي بالهدف
يعني هو مانو تخصصي وانما هو كله كان موجه
لغير المختصين هلا اذا حنحكي عن شويه
ارقام كمان بالنسبه للمخبر السلوكي فكان
في عنا حوالي اول شيء كان في مكتبه كامله
وهذا الموضوع عم بحكي انه وقت اللي بلشنا
شغل فعليا ما كان فيه ولا مقال عن الموضوع
ابدا كنا عم نحكي عن ارقام جدا كبيره كان
في عنا قاموس مصطلحات اكثر من 100 مصطلح
كان في عنا فيديوهات مثلا كنا نحنا يا اما
منعربهم يا اما كنا بنقدمهم على الاقل كتب
كنا بنقدمهم او نلخصهم او اخره مجلات
علميه مقالات فعليا كان في عنا خلال
تقريبا بين سنه ونص للسنتين او يعني اذا
حنكون موضوعين خلينا نقول سنتين اكثر من
500 قطعه محتوى انتجناها بس من خلال مشروع
واحد كان هو اول شيء يعني خلينا نسميه مثل
ما نحن بنقولا
بمعنى كل حدا بيدخل هو في له مفرد بالاخير
كل حدا بيساهم بشيء عم يحصل على مخرج
بالمقابل فالشخص اللي هو دخل مشان تدريبه
وحصل على التدريب اللي بده اياه زائد حصل
على مخرج ثاني اللي هو المقالات نزلت
باسمه واخذ معرض اعمال باسمه بالنسبه لالي
كان اهم مخرج هو انه صار في جزء من
الاشخاص اللي هم انا شفت انه فعلا هذا
المشروع كان قادر انه يامن لهم فرص عمل
هاي من جهه من جهه تانيه اللي هو شغفي
الاول بصراحه
اللي هو المحتوى العربي لما اشوف انا في
عندي اكثر من 500 قطعه محتوى بمجالين انا
بهتم فيهم جدا فانا بالنسبه لي هذا كان
انجاز كتير كبير انا ما كنت اتوقعه بصراحه
وعم نحكي عن مشروع جانبي يعني هو هذا مو
شغلي الرئيسي
زائد بصراحه الفكره انه النموذج اللي كان
موجود انه انا شلون طورته الشيئ اللي بدي
اقوله بصراحه انه هذا النموذج هو مانو هيك
شيء انا اخترعته من الصفر او يعني خلاص
يعني هو شيء خارق لا هو بصراحه هو جزء من
شيء منسميه اقتصاد تشاركي
اقتصاد تشاركي خليني يعني ما حنغوص كتير
يعني بشي تخصصي بس خلينا نشبهه انه هي في
عنا هيك مثل الحلقه كل حدا بيدخل بساهم
فيها بشيء ممكن يكون في مساهمه بالموارد
الماليه موارد بشريه
ابداع ممكن الى اخره بس بالمقابل كل شي
نتائج عم تكون موجوده ضمن هاي الدائره عم
تتوزع على الكل وهذا الشيء يلي ممكن
يفيد اي حدا او اي طرف عم بيدخل هذا
النموذج برايي هو شيء قابل للتعميم بمعنى
كلنا بمجال تخصصنا في عنا مشاكل معينه انا
متاكده من الموضوع
كل حدا فينا يلاقي الحل بضوء الموارد اللي
هو عنده اياها يعني مضطرين كتير نفكر بعيد
نحن فينا نشتغل على شيء وموجود عنا على
موارد موجوده عنا ونفكر شو بدنا نخلق هاي
الحاله بحيث كل الموارد تكون مدخلات
وبالاخير الكل عم بيحصل على المخرجات اللي
هو بده اياها
سالتكم هلا
كم فكره بتخطر لكم باليوم هيك لحلو
وابداعيه طب ما حنقول باليوم بالشهر كم
فكره بتفكروا فيها وبتقولوا انه هاي فكره
عظيمه جدا بس هي بحاجه لحدا يتبناها لانه
انا لحالي ما فيني اشتغل انا متاكده انه
في كل حدا فيكم على الاقل فكره بالشهر
وهذا الشيء كلنا بنمر فيه بس اللي انا بدي
اقوله انه بدل هيدي الفكره ما تضل فكره
وبدل ما المخرج يضل مثلا عم نحكي عن عشره
بالميه او اضافه بنسبه مثلا 50% ممكن يكون
عم نحكي حتى عن اضافه ميه ميه بالميه ما
حدا
فعليا بس الشيء اللي ممكن نحن نكون عم
نركز عليه هو الموارد اللي عنا اياها نكون
عم فكر انه احنا شلون نعمل نموذج بس كل
حدا فينا يكون عم بخلق الموارق بيخلق
الابداع اللي بده اياه بالموارد اللي بده
اياها وخلاص النتائج صار فينا نشوفها صار
فينا نشوف الشيء اللي كنا عم نفكر فيه او
الحل اللي عم فكر فيه هو صار شيء قابل
للتطبيق باسرع مما كنا بنتوقع بس بمجرد ما
نحن اشركنا عده اشخاص اشركنا عده موارد مع
بعض ووصلنا لهذه الحاله اللي كنا بنستفيد
فيها واللي كلنا بنشوف النتائج اللي كنا
عم ندور عليها شكرا
[تصفيق]